- thumbnail first so don't forget to a
bit of thumbnail that's completely
mislead the audience and I think you
would really love this movie
mmm everyone what's going on reject
never talk about transformers the last
night oh my god
my god it's good oppression okay it's
good oppression okay oh boy ah ah man
hey that requiring my ability to just
pay attention it not do the hospital bad
yeah there's a lot of bringing your mind
back to food but better hour and a half
into it I was like oh boy I'm sorry feel
my eyes closed
nope not at a time not this video kind
of vintage it inspired me you know every
thumbnail everyone's is news they're a
couple people like John Rowe Cove
actually liked the film surprisingly
this movie is not a good film you know
I'm very on it you know I'm not going to
do the thing where you introduce a bunch
of positives first and then talk about
its negative no because this film is
just not not a good achievement at all
let's start with the aspect ratio
hahahaha
biggest problem I have with this movie
we've talked to a few people about who
saw before us who said like there's this
weird aspect ratio change it keeps
happening I thought it was like oh it
only happens when you watch it on IMAX
you get it I've seen films like The Dark
Knight where when they play it on IMAX
the aspect ratio changes into the IMAX
camera format and sometimes it's back to
its regular letterboxes if you watch an
IMAX movie at a regular theater it
doesn't do that it just stays in its
regular format the entire time they
converted just for that somewhere along
the line Michael Bay was like we're not
going to do that it's in cricket we
don't care what theatre you're at and
we're going to keep changing the I'm
Adam
the friggin aspect ratio a lot of
different cameras because the picture is
going to change the whole lot end of
whatever man because at first it's like
oh it's IMAX quality is there's two
different IMAX cameras one takes up the
whole screen one takes up most of the
screen and it's not that distracting
when it's really distracting it is when
it says regular film format and the
letter boxes are much more to find yeah
and why it's distracting is because it
keep it keeps interchanging between the
three different cameras and every scene
it's like there are scenes where alright
it's a talking scene yes coverage of
this guy will use the best IMAX camera
coverage of this person let's use the
regular film camera but yeah I don't
hate cutting back before look like what
the hell's going on with this but I
wanted to forgive it but yeah every time
it changed there there started to be
moments where I was like why did you
choose to they didn't seem like there
was any thought as to which camera they
were going to use for what perhaps
that's where that one is beautifully
let's just shoot every scene on all the
cameras and cut between them yeah yeah
humor is sometimes makes you laugh
there's a guy as a father but his
daughter who's sitting next to us who
really laughed a lot he had a 30-minute
sense of humors michaelbay mean sense of
humor everyone's means it transformers
our main Mark Wahlberg's kind of little
racist and Anthony Hopkins is a big
everyone is it's a weird yeah everybody
in the characters everybody this movie
is kind of a dick with their sense of
humor and it seems clear to me that
somebody listen when everybody
complained about their their semi racist
robot and then they like compensate for
that by its still having a lot of them
but then also having random characters
doing that's pretty yeah
beautifully well you can't be like half
woke this movie now isn't is all over
the place like I'm sure our review will
be it's going to be all over the place
oh yeah because this movie is like I
remember right when it launches into
this thing where because you know how
the trailer talks about the night the
rub actually you know what that defines
the realm that is a i'll give this film
I thought in the first 10 minutes when
it is getting the prologue of Arthur and
the knights of the round table and
Merlin and how that's all linked to the
Transformers I was watching and thinking
oh man I wish I wish we just got some
spin-off movie or was only about this
yeah because that was that was all right
to me that wasn't half bad I was
enjoying that and I liked you know
mixing up with the historical fiction
and historical but you know what I mean
I'm mixing it all up Italy drawing from
legend yeah you know timeless tale yeah
and that was that was really neat to me
and it's when the movie becomes what the
movie is really going into it is a
two-and-a-half-hour movie it's all plot
no character there's nothing that can
flake you and you're not going to expect
that from this film I understand that
yeah I don't know it's weird to see one
of these movies that is again two and a
half hour action movie and the thing is
it never really changes its pace ever so
there's just tons of stuff happening all
the time and it's not to me it wasn't
it's the most stuff happening for so
little and Gaya
like it never grabbed you because the
thing is like even in a taksim through
chaos happening we're cutting to a whole
bunch of stuff and like even the
dialogue is shot like action when I get
through this is satisfiable yeah and so
the movie amounts just a lot of people
narrating things to you and you watching
Kulik and b-roll you know I've seen all
the transformers phones and surprisingly
this was the one where I thought it was
the most on even the most horse from the
were structured one of them all again
especially like that first half-hour
you're cutting around to like a lot of
different locations a lot of different
people a bunch of different Transformers
setting up optimistic meet with this
maker who's like in the filming or three
and a half minute leo the recurring
characters in this movie is people that
you see and then kind of go oh I should
probably remember that character because
I'll see them again 40 minutes when we
check back in with them the main plot
point of this is Mark Wahlberg's
character guy Yaeger he's got this this
pendant
thing at you know just [ __ ] the
transformers autobot chosen one I don't
want me to stop leaving [ __ ] behind on
earth is gonna stop this is it really
the Autobots like lost their junk drawer
on earth this special pendant it's like
a seal of some kind that relates balance
all the twelve nights
my latches on to his arm but it actually
travels throughout his body and for what
reason Wesley to Anthony Hopkins
character who knows all about the
Transformers they wants to talk with
Mark Wahlberg and this other British
Megan Fox and so that is I mean is we
just sort of look British Megan Fox is
like that character is it work it's
traded very strangely yeah this is so
there's a whole this whole thing about
having to retrieve this staff that can
help prevent the you know Decepticons or
Medusa's head from taking over or
whatever look the plot of a enchantress
the story doesn't even really matter
that's the problem with this film that
is all plot heavy and by the end you're
like it doesn't really matter
oh yeah this movie feels like it's in a
hurry and you're like dude if this if
you're gonna hide behind the like oh but
these movies are fun they gotta be fun
or something or an ageing somehow people
clap at the end got 15 people out of a
pack Peter glass yeah but I was like
what is where they see that I can't
yeah there are cool moments there are
little moments of humor dude for their
little characters I like here and there
but I liked what they were doing with
Josh Duhamel character yeah I could Josh
the Hamill's in the first three and this
one he's probably part of the military
it's time to a task force it's all about
taking down Autobot yeah and control
keeping them under control but you see
that the thing with the film that
especially because there's a lot of
different characters people to cut
around stand around the first 30 to 40
minutes then around the last 30 to 40
minutes we can - lose two and a half
hours then in the last 30 or 40 minutes
it started cutting back to some of these
people what have little JLo as Mark
Wahlberg called her the girl the
feminist trailer that we had heard the
fourteen-year-old girl Michael Bay
literature pretty much like I feel you
kind of sexualizing like Michael Bay
wants to have sex
it is a little weird it was a little
strange because the main characters are
Mark Wahlberg Anthony Hopkins British
Megan Fox and then their journey and
then Josh Duhamel like randomly chasing
them down and then you got Nana trying
to figure out how to stop this thing
you got JLo a bunch of other
Transformers is chilling you've got
another half before so the chip on their
shoulder led by out quite frank really
then you got whatever is going on with
Optimus Prime on Cybertron happening and
oh yeah and then you have Megatron
assembling a team to take down Jaeger or
something because yeah Megatron's got a
team of similarly gray looking to
septagon then they're going to do
something for the chick in the spaceship
see the problem the biggest issue with
this movie is you got so much going on
and I can literally give zero shits
about anybody was there why didn't any
of these I think at least I've cared in
one of these kinds of movies a long time
by the time you get to oh the world's
going to be destroyed again by the time
you get that part of the movie they're
like my planet is going to crash into
our planet and it's going to obliterate
everything in three days and you feel
none of those things yeah you don't care
there's no reason to care there's
nothing to latch on to the other thing
is during this movie I thought like I
was watching a medley of other movies
but like I said I was watching Game of
Thrones at one point and then I was
watching like a cut-rate Neill Blomkamp
movie at one point and I was watching
alien at one point and I was watching
you know some kind of I was watching
like parts of painting gained another
point uh yeah no it's just like a big
mishmash and then that that rumor about
like the writers room feels like it's
real and you're like did you just crash
like every script into this script cuz
we have six editors six editors are
credited on there something about a
movie so uh
everything everyone say the entire
there's a rector and they hired an
editor then they had another
another one read it and another one to
read it you don't have six dudes at a
computer like gunner it up with all of
our efforts right we make this happen
that it feels really edited like every
the editing is the part perhaps the most
noticeable thing about it is because
it's cutting all the time I mean I like
bumblebee still I new idea dice building
there's little things to like I always
enjoy bumblebee Anahata to still think
he's like the most enjoyable part of
this movie Mark Wahlberg is just not
from Texas anymore let's say never back
to is I saw you extinction in his
characters establish from Texas I don't
even remember if he attend to the
southern accent but now this movie it's
definitely not there he's got a magnet
on his fridge shaped like Texas yeah to
remind you to remind you also this movie
just geography doesn't make it any less
met happens we're we going wait a minute
are we still in Chicago are we in
America where are we yeah and how are
these human beings getting all these
places so fast as the thing is it
becomes like that's just another thing
that makes this less engaging is like
not only do I not know anybody enough to
care about them but also like I don't
even think the stakes really matter
because they're like all Cybertron's
gonna crash into Earth and it's going to
be cataclysmic and it kind of doesn't
not a lot happens i weirdly wouldn't
walk out of this film going it's nonstop
action it's not no and and and it's
times when it's most entertaining is
when there's action scenes going on at
the same time however all these action
scenes are nothing different than what
we've seen from any of the other
Transformers movies so this is Borg if
you know none of this is different
except the the again the medley of
different production value at they
switch between yeah there's no ad
because not one transformers action
sequence feels different than any other
action scene that we've seen from above
like hours of other tracks a Mizzou so
I'm like man a as much as I would say
like once you cut out more story give us
more transformers because the humans are
dull the Transformers are
most interesting part and yet they can't
even they just can't even get that right
this this might be what this is probably
one of the worst ones I've seen of them
all I don't think it's worse than
revenge of the Fallen
okay as I feel like age of extinction at
least had a pretty clear-cut plot of
what was going on
this inventor this amateur inventor with
its family they go on this journey and
they primarily stick to that and it
leads opening more doors with it
sticking to this family and Mark
Wahlberg for the majority of the film
okay here you're like oh yeah I forgot
about these guys oh yeah I forgot about
these guys oh yeah Optimus Prime's in
this movie oh yeah oh yeah oh that's
even occurred to me when he were there
cuz I knew like I forgot his gun in the
movie he didn't yeah Optimus Prime is on
like a fan of the Furious but like in
them way back around like some point
where he's only in a few minutes of it
because I have all these plots of
exhibits they thought in the little
outline that it would be clever how they
all come together in the end that's not
they don't return a low feel honestly
pointless by the end everybody just
shows up at random those kids that you
see in the trailer those like stranger
things cap they had going on all of
their scenes or all those things are all
their deities like that's it there's one
other scene of them like talking and
getting shot at by ed-209 and like he
was like why here focus is these guys
there's nothing yeah why Simon elder
movie I mean I can't even remember this
action scene was in another one but I
think a cool action scene was when
bumblebee is disassembled and as he's
reassembling he's fighting people that
was that was cool that was a proud thing
I would say the coolest parts of this
movie are honestly within its first 40
minutes before it gets to its main plot
when I got through its main plot I mean
no teacher ever is that to you like oh
I'm so glad that we waited like 40
minutes they get to the main police
start the minute he acted just like a 40
minute is set up of all his other [ __ ]
when you pointed this out at the end
going back to the not not showing us
much of anything new with the action
past that first 40 minutes by the end of
it it almost seems like it's gotten
easier to kill Decepticons and stuff
well yeah yeah so the stakes get even
lower yeah because when often is
awesomeness doesn't company he's like in
the begin
for a bit and these in the end for like
the last 20 or so minutes and I'm going
to give you as a minor spoiler a very
minor spoiler a minor hint of a spoiler
there's a Martha scene as a Martha
seananners right when it happened I went
Martha and don't know how it works and
it's not 100% Martha no one says Optimus
Prime's name but when it happens it's a
Martha moment it definitely and once if
you haven't seen the film or if you have
seen the film you you will know what I
am talking about and you haven't and
then you go watch it you're gonna be
like oh that's the memo mark and it'll
be kind of a popular myth and they're
all just build-up for nemesis bribe yeah
and there are and there are a lot of
those kinds of moments hidden in the
other plots - were just like special
things will just work out right now I
need them to this one time only and then
and then there's a lot of deus ex
machina in yeah there are things that I
thought I would like the one work up the
the helper he had the employee Mark
Wahlberg had the black guy than 31 even
one of my favorite characters I have
five minutes to and I even liked the you
know robot human size Butler yeah at
times I liked him at times he was kind
of annoying but that's only because of
the choice of editing and jokes they
were choosing to do with him that got on
my nerves
British Megan Fox was a much better
actress than Megan Fox but I couldn't
help but think you look like British
Megan Fox
yeah and that was like a cake and eat it
too character where I'm like you're
trying to make her like strong will but
you've always got her in the most
impractical yeah sexy ass clothes like
your home is insulting her intelligence
as a Randy Hopkins he does a good job
he'd have any Hopkins you're gonna do a
good job looks like he was having a good
time at the yeah - did he look like he
was invested in what he was doing or
like he wandered off onto the set and -
started saying whatever and that is
somehow kind of interesting - one yeah
because he's kooky in this and at least
that stands out bottom line of this
movies all over the place gives you
really nothing to watch on - it doesn't
gravitate to you in any way
emotionally and if anything it's just a
big repetitive mess of all the other
ones there's nothing I didn't even end
on a new note it just ends in a similar
note like how all the other ones have
ended and ends in roughly like the other
ones here
yeah it just stops and then there's a
mid credit sequence that did nothing but
nothing but got excited for things
because it involves some stuff that I
actually didn't like yes and because
Michael Bay is sending up a part six I
just really doubt he's not gonna return
and I you know honestly I might not even
watch this if Michael Bay shoots the
sixth one I might just go I'm not coming
back to this I was like at five movies
deep this is not how this should look
and this is like I walked out of this
having not seen the last couple and
going yeah I don't think I need to go
check out the next couple Aude sniffs
that exchange somehow is so dull like
even I can't oh yeah care about anything
is there a no stake because there's a
lot the one day I think it's really
telling there's one character little
recurring plot character in this movie
played by the guy from from like veep or
something he's always ranting on about
physics and the movie kind of hates that
character and that's very telling
because this movie doesn't give a [ __ ]
about Sid not even that even in a movie
this only seems to be concerned with its
plot and its physical and its action if
you're going to [ __ ] all over that and
the nothing is of any stakes and and I
don't care there were just quote there
was cool things that were setting up to
explore I'd like I liked how you know
Chicago had it like own Ground Zero we
had this more sci-fi apocalyptic feel
where this is alien restricted
territories I thought that stuff was
like cool out we get a cent more time
here I would love to see that city a
little I liked all that stuff it's just
when I think it just turns in a typical
transformer it plot heavy transformers
left something behind that's the secret
Megatron wanted Optimus want like it's
all the same done over and over again
all this and the only the only part of
this plot that actually kind of works
out and toward the end when it sort of
becomes a war
like when they're finally doing the
climactic operation and they're working
on regular earth and then up on that
space thing the Transformers are coming
there are times where you're like oh
like it seems like some of these things
just developed like real situations well
it like plans have work and they adjust
and there's no real clear-cut villain in
here - it's like Megatron's around and
enchantress maker is around but you
don't really hear [ __ ] yeah like I like
I've seen this plot line before and also
I just you're not gonna win so yeah like
and there's nothing else to take my mind
off of that there's nothing that makes
this fun for me decide that
the other cool thing that I thought was
there was they had this weapon where
women when a transformer shoots it it
like slows down time that was cool dad
like in this little spear this little
bubble yeah I was a cool weapon you see
like the only things that were cool and
different were bumblebee of some himself
and fighting people at the same time
while he's assembling an Iron Giant also
the time stopper thing and that was it
that was as all as I was rewarding about
it so yeah those two things other than
that if it's a loud incoherent Aaron
mess that ideas I will never watch again
you can't you when I for fun it's not
even fun bad itch is bad
yeah I thought tweet once it said if you
missed the new Transformers movie just
have someone push you down the stairs
and throw Legos at you exactly what you
can save time doing it and money well
subscribe to the real rejects quick that
notification valve - John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house check out our
patreon for the exclusive perks and
video content we got over there as a
whole lot of fun we're having go have a
good rest of your